merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
je suis outré
la chênaie à delaune à rennaz au tac obs
et là et gachon bas
[Applaudissements]
gbagbo
les balais
mon cas
je ne peux pas
les tunisiens
rocard
les écarts
show mode les
marchés
[Applaudissements]
un vrai challenge
je m'en parlait matin
c'est au taf les côtes brooks et pour
les fiches de
ses collègues
corey jane doe
hall est fait
et chamakh
[Applaudissements]
je vous entends pas
on est une femme
mail
[Musique]
j'aime bien
juan est là
désolé menti
[Applaudissements]
non
mettez du centre
je demandai je
[Musique]
ces batteries
pas du tout
viendra
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aïe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il était juste ce qu'il faut
moi
je vois deux minutes et qui dégage quant
à monique eleb addictif
c'est thomas froid sur ce contrat non
elle va t'asseoir chaque lundi qu'elle a
besoin d'une petite sirène vérifier
qu'il est sur la liste quand même bien
sûr au monde schouppe et roselyne
choukroun
voisine est demandé sur la piste c'est
reparti on va refaire un petit tour du
côté du sol et quant à l'instant
jet-setteur j'habitais fils vous ont
préparé un magnifique à la reine aux
anges vous pourrez bien sûr après ce
petit tour du côté de lorient allait
manger et après bien sûr ce sera la
soirée discothèque
où jérémy la flopée de jérémy avec une
pièce montée
son atout majeur ni des crises on
[Applaudissements]
a laissé mon parti or pas du côté du
ciel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
j'aime
je
si je n'existais pas
est passé à troquer
à
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire à chaque
fois
montagny
je m'habille 1
[Musique]
et tu as trahi qui
jamais
mais
richard hayes
à
allez
[Musique]
hicham ayouch avait mal de gens
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les chats et chattes t'en va pas et
chabrette avec nous mais chérie je
demande à l'état
demander de leur redonner le tarn
les traiteurs six parties s'étaient
emparés de magnifiques bricoleur
vous avez décalage chacun accompagné de
deux ans dit
ça vous allez nantes ou restaurés juste
après on va faire un petit tour du côté
d'ibiza
ouais donc ce pari de vol de perdure
sachez que josé invite
la belle-soeur du frère de shearing
est venu me voir et il m'a dit thiery
syrie
mais c'est de la famille sarkozy syrie
si rim j'aimerais beaucoup faire une
surprise à shirin
punit déjà la surprise c'est une
enveloppe que tu va nous donner
une enveloppe
acculé des gages aux iem qui est un très
beau geste
mais josiane m'a dit non je veux faire
plus et josiane
elle est avec nous ce soir
et elle a décidé de chanter à gérer ni
une chantant une chanson sa chanteuse
préférée
sa chanteuse préférée tout le monde la
connaît pas sur son vrai nom puisqu'on
voit le sa peine
bernadette manque rien
mais le grand public la connaît sous le
nom de whitney houston
josiane merci d'être avec nous je
voudrais tu vas donc nous apprêter nous
inquiète nous apprêter ça nous a prêté
tu veux dire je serai toujours dans les
bandes main
est toujours mal est fait jusqu'à 120
ans
josiane sachez qu'elle a fait les
auditions à la venue
chez marco las vegas ah oui quand-même
chausseur
maîtres en santiags
josiane je maîtrise et micro
[Rires]
allez
merci vous
on a besoin
d'eux je suis
[Rires]
complètement fou
de ce couple
un peu plus tôt des vols
[Rires]
[Musique]
pas
d'accord mais guéri mais je
me bats
[Musique]
et
les fossoyeurs
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon je tiens tu vas arrêter cette
mascarade
je viens tu vas arrêter cette mascarade
a offert un petit tour du côté bien sûr
où la discothèque je vais demander bien
sûr à toute l'équipe de notre marque est
notre orchestre et avait peu joué
remercier d'ailleurs les deux chanteuses
josiane et bryan
qui sont avec nous qu'ils font un
travail magnifique
jouet qu'on nous mêmes pour démarrer
cette soirée discothèque single est une
gamme c'est le dernier tube de docteur
allemand qui s'était arrêtée pendant le
coc vide 1
c'est parti sing hallelujah j'ai demandé
à tous de vous lever et de rendre
hommage à la dernière chanson que nous a
fait chaud ce soir
c'est parti pour sing hallelujah est-ce
que vous êtes prêts
[Musique]
total de jérémy tous mettent
généralement sur scène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
colère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai pas touché
le soufflé
tout le monde avec toi
mais
c'est parti
c'est
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]